coming in hot wednesdays yeah good
wednesday boys hot wednesday it's hot
wednesday toasty it's toasty it's toasty
but it's that's fine i like the toast i
like i like when it's dry mm-hmm i like
it hot i don't like it and i'm out i put
the top down now it's because it calls
again the titties out so i get the tits
out get that
out you saw me with the tits out yeah
you were shaking them i had a call from
my buddy andy this is this cracked me up
my buddy andy goes hey dude i i've never
really stopped episode nope uh a buddy
of mine from indiana he he goes i love
your podcast dude i love your podcast he
goes listen to every one of them somehow
finally he gets me through my day yeah
he loves it he goes now but i just i i
brendan he just went a little hard on
you and i want to see if you're all
right i'm like what he goes
when you were opening about
when you were
out because when you were opening about
your dad and i was so in i was so in and
and i was yeah i was so moved by how
open you were and then he goes he
started
listening with making an impression of
you with your retainers he's like i'll
throw that up and he goes and he goes
like this he goes i know you guys are
really good friends i go oh no no but
he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah no no but he's
also a piece of [ __ ]
you saw him down pretty [ __ ] hard i
know you guys are brothers i go no but
you're right he's a terrible person and
a piece of [ __ ]
the thing is you haven't been watching
the show for too long if you think
that's abnormal not normal i said i said
and and i said did you ask him did you
find it funny though of course you know
you know
he was cracking up no they were all
loving it yeah they're all loving it i
said i said you have to understand that
me and all my friends were all comics
misfits and we all suck we're all
terrible to each other yeah yeah and on
top of that somebody asked me i was
going to do this project and they said
you can get some of your stand up uh
buddies to to you know some of your
famous buddies to help out and i said
no i can't yeah i wouldn't
i wouldn't
wrangle those animals it'll hurt my
feelings because they all have something
to do i was like i can't get anybody to
do anything that's just the way we are
yeah it's like
a side note uh i was in kansas city this
past weekend uh no yeah well yeah this
past weekend yeah first of all cold as
[ __ ]
don't do it don't do it again not doing
it
it was it was it was it was tough but
wisconsin this weekend but it was it was
dope because uh
you know as i'm starting to like
headline on my own more and like more
fans are starting to come out like so
this so i did that club a year ago
um but this time around i want to say i
had more fans than more yeah then that's
how you know that way they're working
yeah it's like don't worry marketing
sell less tickets yeah i'm not doing
something right here no so it was it was
actually pretty dope but they they it's
it's cool to see how much
like they just [ __ ] with us so heavy you
can't say it just like well because i
know what it is when i go out with you
but like to go on my own yeah and feel
that it's like [ __ ] it's it's it's
it's a don't feel the best feeling in
the world oh yeah it's insane because if
you're not selling tickets
it's personal yeah yeah you're just
selling dates you're like
i'm not saying i killed it out there i'm
just saying but it does especially for a
first starter in comparison to last year
when i did that club i like i i had more
fans than i had people that were like
you'd be taking these nights right now
how many more tickets you sell than
people you think
am i right 100
there are a lot of people whenever i if
i ever bemoan ticket sales
don't use some big words
but i then you see how other people a
lot of people who don't have podcasts
who you would know yeah it's not easy
no
listen like i said i'm not saying i
[ __ ] killed it out there but like
you know enough to where i was like wow
you know like cool you know i was doing
like the meet and greets and stuff and
you know that's what's weird to me is
when you're walking down the street
whatever city you're in right and you'll
see a fan like dude biggest fan what are
you doing sacramento
drives me nuts oh yeah what it drives me
nuts well not just hanging out dude
i was like i'm on he's like dude i love
the shows i listen every episode
all right
i'm here i posted yesterday i was in
sacramento doing comedy drives me nuts
it isn't the same thing to be like
they're always like so confused as to
why you're in their i always say that
people knew if all those people who were
fans in that city knew i was good yeah
yeah but you have a couple of venues hey
stop playing and go to kansas city they
want you there really stopping cities
it's just cold that's a great it's
called
i was a little bored but oh i i didn't
have seen the [ __ ] live music
what did he say the jazz scene oh yeah
brian
i'm sorry
yeah you went to the gym really late man
no you didn't i go you do not i've been
with you bro there's nobody out there
with you we didn't because here's the
thing jazz is at night you perform at
night show i'm doing a show hey i'm not
in a court of law right now all i'm
saying is like man you catch a chief's
game like yeah right well you're on
stage yeah
i uh
look man they had good barbecue though
like joseph yeah joe's and then they got
q39 and some other 239 is really good
yeah they got some other spots no no but
as far as like the crowds [ __ ]
amazing yeah yeah because they were like
brian we saw brian he came out here
showed us love they're like you came out
here they're like where's brendan you're
gonna think you're gonna you're gonna
actually yeah they said it's better
you're gonna think i'm kidding but the
truth is i do go to jazz bars there and
here's why before my show you can have
you can start it like four
and you go some of the best [ __ ] live
jazz and singers name a venue and then
afterwards
you went to
uh give us one i went to two yeah
hold on let's catch in like
name a venue and then name the artist
you said fine
okay
i'm gonna do it all right
because when you took those shrooms and
made you tell the truth
yeah you said i never want to lie again
hey i went to jeff i went to the lakers
game last time with jeff who's mr laker
yeah like he knows everything about
mascots apparently i guess but really no
he's like you might as well work for the
lakers yeah like we were courtside like
that jenny bus was like loves them we
sat next to her she's buying us drinks
all night she's the best yeah he's like
mister you know he invited me because
you couldn't make it and then he goes i
go oh let me check my schedule like he
is you want to come shop cancel like oh
let me yeah i mean the lakers me and
jeff you know my new friend and then uh
i get this text hey man
shoves in uh sorry brother next time i'm
like
i'm in the middle of making it i'm like
all right no because my girlfriend you
are i was like oh no originally not
gonna do it originally i couldn't go i
told him i could then i'm like gosh [ __ ]
dude i gotta do something do something
not going to work out and then an hour
later i'm like oh i'm back in and he
goes you know what the best part about
this is telling calendar he can't go
i thought he was joking nope the old guy
i'm second place like oh i got my young
friend yeah i'm like alright guys hey
people really really liked uh jeff on
that he was great he's cool he's great
he's so funny great he's still so
fighter i also got a drinking buddy like
no you guys none of you guys drink like
oh he mean him drink is he is he he's a
bourbon
yeah all night last night he's all man
and
he
is
he's all man and i i [ __ ] love him i
love everything about the guy i like his
sensibility i like his point of view
he's so hilarious because like with
jenny bus i don't you know she owns the
lakers like she makes the calls yeah and
he was in her air he's like you know he
[ __ ] up letting caruso go right and
she's like in the middle of the game
middle of the game i mean he met drinks
and he's all you know you [ __ ] up when
caruso go with that terrible hairline
you see what he's doing for chicago
lately she's like what like she's like
trying to focus on the game it's like
what he's like yeah he made a mistake
with russell westbrook didn't she's like
hey jeff will you bath
it's so funny and she's a [ __ ] owner
can i make a can i make a call here am i
am i wrong in saying that he's
first team all dime pieces oh he's
better looking than anyone right
listen i enjoy it like oh he upstairs
last night at the game no one looked at
me no nobody he's six five and and
handsome is all
you got the swoop of the hair i mean
he's a great way better looking than
that i mean in person he's just a much
better looking guy yeah
and and who's that probably somebody
famous christian calgary he dates
whoever he wants christian cavalieri
yeah from uh the uh was yeah i know who
christopher cavallari is we just said
who's that he's just funny no i said
who's that
he's a woman he's he's funny and tall
and handsome as [ __ ] no he's really
funny man yeah he's hilarious he's a
great guy and he's dated every hot chick
i've ever made that's right yeah
yep now when i tell you like he's mr
laker dude he
everyone the owners kurt rambis the
players everyone they all know and i go
dude you come to every game with every
game man
every game every game
oh wow he was every just hanging did you
grew up in l.a no he grew up in seattle
seattle yeah wow he's telling a story
when theo this is they said like 2005
2006 when theo was coming off the real
world and said he wanted to stand up he
only had 20 minutes with his headline he
only had 20 minutes he goes this is my
introduction to theo vaughn he goes theo
comes seattle sells my home club out
sells it out he says i'm there every
weekend theo sells it out in minutes
and the manager goes hey we need you to
you know headline this thing he's like
well no theory sold out he's like yeah
but theo's only doing 20. so theo's
going to come out do 20. you got to do
an hour
you know so i did an hour i did the
brunt of the work but i got paid like
feature yeah he goes i did five hours of
comedy i got 200 bucks man he goes
that's my life in a nutshell he's so
great he's so funny he's he did does he
play basketball i don't think he plays
with his sports as much as he just he
just enjoys he's into yoga and drinking
yeah
he goes uh i love him more he goes
because i like to go to hot yoga and
just sweat it out man i do every day
with every day i just get in i sweat it
out have you seen this show on hbo
righteous gemstones
uh oh
yeah man it's a great show now for seven
years it has at least yeah it has yeah
there's a new season and when you're all
on the fourth you know where you are
when you're old you're an interruption
that [ __ ] writes and directs it
great uh uh danny mcbride yeah he's got
it
he's a [ __ ] beast he's a monster that
shows fantastic i've seen all the shows
that's the best show he's done so yeah
i've only seen two apps he's found it
down was pretty good that was pretty
funny oh he's pounding down so he's
might be my
he's great in movies his character he's
so honest yeah he's so funny though he's
so he's pounding down too look at the
way he stands look at the way he's bound
down is so funny oh his level of
delusion is a [ __ ] retirement yeah
trying to come back
with the third season he goes to mexico
yes
he has zero mexico my brother loved that
[ __ ] zero vanity like no vanity yeah
no he's [ __ ] to be yeah he's he's
been in the game for a minute too danny
mcbride he got famous off that uh yeah
way yeah yeah what was that will ferrell
who was it fist of fury i think i
thought it was will ferrell saw it was
like this guy's hilarious and started
putting in things he blew that you teach
jiu-jitsu no
yeah he's a [ __ ] he's a beast dude
but he just started uh yeah so you just
started yeah i mean you know
i mean you're not too far off 2019
that's not bad though no i mean the s
but if it's a funny [ __ ] show eric
andre's on there too yeah as fast as
news travels though you know what's this
pete divine what's his atom device
sausage parties hilarious too
oh so good
yeah he's bounding down it's hilarious
right
dude he's great in that one of my
favorite movies is this is the end where
it's james franco seth rogen it's so
[ __ ] funny it is we honest in it i
think yeah she dies yeah but like yeah
it's like what everybody does the foot
fist way yeah hilarious look at him
let's watch the trailer for a second
here are you allowed to no no we can't
get kicked off we'll get demonetized
[ __ ]
sorry it's awesome
you would do a podcast for a minute
can we play some metallica yeah
i just wanted to do it
i'm trying to think of the the jazz bar
that's okay
kc kc's
i saw one of the greatest performers
i've ever seen there actually a jazz guy
one of the greatest showman casey or
casey how great was it
i'm not oh you went to the kansas city
juke house uh yeah
i went to casey it never happened but
tell us this fake story yeah yeah so
they interacted with this the greatest
jazz musician you've ever blue room i
went to the blue room yeah yeah and then
i went to the phoenix yeah you've been
all those uh-huh phoenix you went to the
club
mardi gras yep i went to that one too i
went to the phoenix i think okay
i went to the green lady lounge that's
not as good they've been all of them not
as good oh yeah it's a little too dark
for me so here's the thing i think the
both of us have slept on helix
mattresses
i sleep on every night brian callan yes
and uh you don't get better than that
you don't get better than the healing
mattress why would we call them why
would you want a regular just come it
comes like all like it comes futuristic
yeah like all mashed up and then it just
opens yeah you don't sleep on a regular
mattress you need a mattress that's
built just for your thick ass helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type with the perfect mattress just for
your body
i took the helix quiz and man it
match me with this mattress i can't i'm
a side sleeper i'm not i'm a back
sleeper and every time i sleep though i
think to myself this is going to sound
weird but i always feel lucky when i get
into too much too much okay i feel like
i know but i do i go sure some people
have to sleep on wood and on hay and i
get to sleep
okay
yeah so if you're looking for a mattress
you take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to comes right to
your door shipped for free you don't
even need to go to a match store ever
again all right just go to
helixsleep.com take their two-minute
sleep quiz they'll match you with your
perfect mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty also you can try it out
for 100 nights risk free they even pick
it up if you don't love it but you will
so don't rewarded number one best
overall mattress picks of 2020 by gq and
wired mac yes helix is offering you guys
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free
pillows listeners and viewers of firing
the kid helix sleep.com
fighter modes to your body
i want to know something about peloton
here's my question dude i like to box i
like music i like other kinds of
workouts i don't necessarily always want
to you don't have a ton of time you have
a lot of time yeah 20 minutes 15 minutes
30 minutes yeah full body weight i want
somebody to guide me and bring me
through it so do you have you want to
keep it fresh and you like tunes dude
you know i've been a member of pelton
for about six years now i can't get
enough of them yes uh my name on there's
thick boy prez all right and also boxing
they're adding some new stuff for 2022.
pelton is stepping into the ring that's
right no gloves needed discover a fast
furious workout and it's super fun man
and you got the peloton instructors in
your corner all right which keeps you
motivated right it's fun and it keeps
you motivated
i love their music they have pop rock
hip hop edm
100 artist series to choose from yeah
dude you can work on pelton every day
man 30 minutes of strength 20 minutes of
cardio do a quick 15 minute total body
class before whatever you want man visit
one peloton dot com to learn more that's
one peloton.com o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
but they got workouts yoga meditation
dance cardio and more oh dude how about
we didn't talk about i'm sure it's
incredible how about that kane velazquez
oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah that shit's [ __ ] no i think
what happened it's a terrible no we know
what happened yeah so so it's yeah so
kane had a four-year-old daughter who um
was going to this day care of this lady
i guess was a friend of the family and
one of the workers in the daycare
supposedly this is the news molested the
girl over a hundred times and other kids
over a hundred times a manner or a man
yeah he's like so he's like 30 or 43
years old 40 40 40 43 i think
so kane became aware of that
dude the guy gets
convicted of this three three accounts
of child molestation they let him out on
bail game house arrest no they [ __ ]
yeah because you know that's what they
do because california's so loose
so if you're kane as a father brian
think about this if you're kane that guy
does that you [ __ ] 100 times four four
years old yeah so kane goes oh hell no
oh my god uh it says police say uh kane
is suspect of shooting a man in the area
uh last week's shift debuts arrested
fourth year old eugene
uh at san martin daycare center he's
facing charges of lewd acts with a child
but he's currently out of jail on his
own
without any bond please uh police
sources close to the investigation as
well as friends of the family tell nbc
uh the alleged abuse victim is related
to the last yeah so i don't know if this
is i i i sympathize 100 percent so
sources say gloria and his father were
in the car and kane elegy shot at on
monday and the father was hit but the
father
uh is he's he's not gonna die thank god
for cain here's my thing with this and i
don't know what
what um so it says the taco around his
king chased down two men riding a
vehicle one of them was accused of abuse
of one of kane's children at daycare i
keep hearing it's his four-year-old
daughter this is her thought to be his
daughter yep so the other person
involved is the father cain shot the
father of alleged abuser but i heard
that was on acting he meant to shoot the
yes guy the father apparently jumped in
front of the bullet i believe yeah my
thing is is when i saw gunn and kane did
you touch my kid the gun's the last
thing i'm going to do especially
i have skills canis skill skills the
last thing you would do is let you know
with your bare hands yeah
no i'm going to beat him with an inch of
his life and then piss on him put on my
instagram yeah and that's going to
happen every single month i'm going to
come back around every single month i'm
not going to let you out easy and just
shoot you that's too easy man right
but i don't want to live in a world
where a guy's child at four years old is
molested and takes action in his own
hands and then kane goes away for how
long are you going to put away for
attempted murder i'll try to do it for
15 to life i think you know in this case
what you can do there has to be some
sympathy well i think a good lawyer a
good lawyer and i think by the way if
this is going to cost him some money and
i think if there's anything if there's
any charity
charity any any any support here
everybody should be helping him with
this in one way or another but i'm sure
someone's starting to go from if they
haven't whatever it is i'm all over it
yeah i'll donate
whatever they want this is a this is a
special hashtag free kane and yeah
hashtag free kane couple things about
this one is
um
i i think that
hopefully
hopefully a good lawyer can say he went
he he he went it was an insanity he went
out of his mind because he found out
additional information at the house or
he saw his daughter or something and he
just said or i'm going to go kill this
guy i think a jury and i certainly think
a judge would be sympathetic to that a
jury definitely will yes he wanted to go
to germany and you judge i think it's i
think there are certain sentencing
guidelines but i think that the d.a will
bring charges but the da's also very
aware this is political and so i i
whether they charge with it he's
probably gonna be charged with attempted
murder and because i think he did try to
ram the truck off the road a couple of
times that news hasn't been reported
yeah but my thing is is yeah
but california is lucy goosey with real
criminals yes actual criminals hopefully
he'll get murdered hopefully he gets so
if you want to be loosey-goosey you do
it with a guy with a jackpot being a
great human being that's right he has no
previous record he's a great father one
of the greatest if not the greatest
heavyweight champion of all time like
has a great track record we're we're
just going to dismiss all that and then
you have dude real criminals rapists
yeah people that murder rob and you give
them loosey-goosey senses yeah you put
them back on the street and that's why
you mean like the guy was like that's
why he climbs through the room
you came after you well yeah you're
pretty loosey-goosey with the guy who is
charged with molesting a kid over a
hundred [ __ ] times and there's other
victims
what world do we live in
no that guy shouldn't be on this planet
no yeah if if anything you should give
kane a goddamn key to the city yeah for
doing what the cops can't do legally
well you put this guy in a ring with
kane and then to see what happens but
but uh overall i think hopefully
hopefully he he ends up doing a year or
something you know
and by the way when he comes out he's a
hero everybody's standing in line to
give him opportunities then i'm with ben
askren i don't want to live in a country
where you can't shoot someone who
sexually abused your child i agree we
all feel that now we don't want the
purge but no but
yeah yeah we want justice but yeah
free cane there i'm just surprised cain
used a gun i really am with his skill
set it's like dude i think he'd be so
crazy yeah i think yeah like
he would probably just yeah i'll kill
this [ __ ] like it's just
probably it's just an initial i'm with
kyle was it kyle crutch mayor he would
read this i don't hear anything else
about ct or really any other [ __ ] this
dude protected his family they released
a scumbag i've always been taught to
protect my family and that's at any cost
agree 100 that's right yeah because
people immediately went to the cte
thing
we all feel this because it's an easy
cop-out no no no no no all of us feel
this way he's it's ct this isn't this is
a a father a good father so i'm saying
like his child was molested over a
hundred times man i i think
there's got to be something where he's
this is all going to be taken into
account i don't know though i don't know
how a court of law works i really don't
prosecutors you know prosecutors have to
take this case prosecutors have to
they're they're aware it's politically
charged there where there's no real
there's no real upside for them to put
him away for a long time no there's no
re there's no upside for the d.a but
there's no ups but they're going to try
to find it but if i'm the defense team
i'm i'm bringing up so many examples of
actual scumbags who have gotten such
light sensitivity yeah it's not real
crime what i think they have to do is
the crime itself was you shot somebody
you you you you pre-meditate you grabbed
a gun got in the car drove
at the found them
tried to get them off the road and then
shot to try to kill the guy correct that
is what the state's going to bring that
is that is the crime for sure and the
defense teams go but why did he act like
this with no previous so then he was
different that's why this first degree
murder secondary murder there's there's
there's uh plea by insanity
i bet he gets eighteen months if less
it'd be great it's less than that yeah
yeah it'd be great oh and that that that
pedophile that child molester
oh you think he's safe no hey he if he
goes to prison he's super [ __ ] there's
nobody more effective to put him in
special prisons for sure but he's on the
street right now and now this is out
yeah mccain is love bite i don't know a
single person who hates on cain
velasquez i don't know he's the baddest
man on the planet for he was for the
longest time oh and he doesn't have
hardcore mexican fans not at all oh and
they're not in the area that guy lives
there
how do you think that guy's life yeah
hardcore yeah yeah exactly and mexican
people aren't family oriented and they
they can't they can't oh they're right
or [ __ ] diving are you kidding me
do over a hundred times and then other
children four years old tim kennedy post
itself four years old tim kennedy on his
instagram posted a kidnapping uh uh uh
an attempted kidnapping okay
and it's [ __ ] unbelievable and you
want to see what evil is you want to see
what evil is where there's that girl
right there she's a little girl she's at
the ice cream thing now this woman see
that guy on the phone right there yeah
he's just talking you see the car with
the door open
see that car with the door open does
this lady know what's going on she's she
watched what she does this is
fascinating because this little girl's
here now that guy you want to see evil
look at that piece of [ __ ] now this guy
this guy this is how they set things up
there's a car there there's a driver and
there's a door okay and if you wonder
what how people just get taken in broad
daylight this is the people that do this
i don't know we should find out where
it's at
but this woman see women women have
better antennae than men she's she
notices something's up something about
this guy she doesn't quite believe he's
on the phone which she's not and he's
just hanging out no she is now watch how
she saves this child
this is this is unbelievable
jesus christ man this is what they do
people this there are people who are
that evil i can't fathom that kind of
evil i can't fathom it now watch
watch this ready
now all he's going to do is try to he's
going to push the car thank god for this
woman
see that punk [ __ ]
oh my god dude [ __ ] don't you want to
kill him wow i didn't sleep last night
thinking about killing that guy
i want to kill that guy i want them to
die holy shnikes now he that's what they
do those guys that's what they do that's
their job
right
that woman saved that child from god
knows what right well
that's tim goes oh [ __ ] this young woman
was one step away from permanent
imprisonment a life of addiction rape
until she finally dies all of what will
happen three to five years oh look she's
getting a picture of the company i
didn't see this part
yeah that girl's a badass i love her so
[ __ ] nice too man i love her
jesus christ
i don't want to say that i just i was
like
pants
is that captain america yeah where is
this and i wonder i bet you in the
comments you'll find out he says
rightly
what is this
selling ice cream kalily has street
savvy but i think her name's khalid yeah
god the world is so dark man i mean when
you see that you go
you don't realize how evil they're
they're the evil in the world yeah when
you're when you're a cop who deals with
that stuff that's that's how you live
i mean [ __ ] man
i don't know where is she
you can see it in the comments no i
think that was it
i think it was like next brazil it might
be brazil or mexico wherever these
places are yeah i think that was her
name yeah i was looking up her name oh
god to see if there's a story on her
yeah with this little girl
god that's terrible man
how would you how
i mean
yeah because this isn't the move you've
taken you're not gonna no yeah it's gone
forever dude that's right this isn't
taken
you're so screwed man
i mean you know
anyway
chin is now uh you're now
emailing ice cream ice cream ice cream
woman kalily saves child and there's
nothing nothing yeah so i mean sometimes
these videos
i'm not saying it's not real though
sometimes no i'm saying sometimes
they're like reenactments to help people
be aware that's interesting that is true
that is true actually
but i mean if it's real that's nice this
footage is so shitty yeah i'm
i'm not that skeptical i think she
actually did this yeah i hope this
happens but i that's a good yeah but
yeah it does save this child and that's
because you see this and i've seen those
those reenactments yeah
but you can see it in the comments i'll
tell you if it's fake or not you you can
see it also the way the guy reacts is
very strange mm-hmm
[Music]
man oh man i know
fields is brazil they're killed in
brazil
this one says it seems set up the girl
just hands her a handful of coins like
it doesn't even count any of it seems
scripted
oh that's interesting
the whole thing is orchestrated fake
says this is stage b oh it's educational
now click on the replace chat okay
pretty sure you're the one who isn't
living in reality here's the second
video good fine
oh
let's see
is it the same hot chick
we'll find out kids
she's brazilian she's probably an
actress
she should start with this oh yeah there
you go
that's the exact same that's a different
uh yeah that's probably the same girl
she has the same body it's definitely
the same girl
same oh she's doing the same thing
you know what she's doing it's the same
car too she's fighting the girl right
though wait wait is that she's fighting
car you know i don't like your attitude
[Laughter]
it happens i don't like your attitude
calling this support that's her running
right there yeah yeah oh damn okay you
know what most of the most of the abuse
to children happens from family members
people that know the child
it was also sex trafficking
yeah but they they no that's absolutely
their own children yep yes that does
happen that's what's beyond terrible you
know
boy this is dark yeah yeah we got real
dark so hopefully yeah i'm glad that's
fake yeah yeah yeah
and people can learn from it people can
learn from yes
the guy and kill him yeah
especially i wanted his death all i did
was all night i couldn't sleep i was
fast about fantasizing about killing him
my girl was like you have to stop
fantasizing about killing that [ __ ]
about
yeah you think about killing that guy
and then you also think about uh [ __ ]
steven seagal fighting in russia just
two fake videos
you just so easily do make videos
getting older my man yeah
getting older
mm-hmm
that happens right i've watched the
state of the union
i did that
how was it anything good come out of it
it's just it's just he put his foot down
saying that if we come together we can
solve all the problems that make america
the country but i heard he acts like
everything's all good he sure does yeah
i heard that he was like we're crushing
us yep it's like really yep he sure did
he sure did he's like i'm absolutely
crushing it yep damn's like okay well
yeah it was interesting it was a
feel-good thing a lot a lot of applause
breaks then there was one point usa i
liked that he said i'm a capitalist but
you know let's let's have the very
wealthy pay their fair share he also
said anybody who makes under 400 000 a
year won't pay a dime more in taxes i
appreciated that i was like all right
yeah
now if that is actually true we'll see
yeah because a lot of times they just be
saying [ __ ] oh yeah yeah that i was
worried he was gonna say some [ __ ] about
about russia and putin that we couldn't
back up
like saber rattling to the point where
it was like and we're gonna force like
no they they and then kamala harris i
saw one of the quotes you saying we're
not sending troops no russia because the
problem is they had a meeting today
though i think they agreed i hope so
because eastern ukraine is mostly
russian so yeah it's like but the the
real numbers came out of uh people
civilians that died two that over two
thousand is that that's how marine yeah
holy [ __ ] corner fox news over 2000 wow
the the thing is um
they were showing a lot of like fake
that so a lot of news organizations got
duped as well um because they they were
like [ __ ] from 2015 with just a bunch of
missiles hitting yeah they thought it
was like a video game and the news
organization was playing it and they
were like well this is outrageous
have you seen the video of the ukraine
soldiers they you know this [ __ ] up some
russian who's in a tank yeah and they
jump in the tank and the tanks are like
from the 40s
the ukraine is like jesus look at this
[ __ ] has like cloth seats it's just
super old but then there's like a lot of
equipment are really is really old they
had a general on who said they also have
these this artillery with these missiles
that can take an area the size of uh
central park and reduce it to dust in
for sure literally a couple of minutes
so
yeah
i guess it's just they had another
general on the like a current american
general who's like this is big bad
russia he goes do you know what we would
do to them yeah like he was this
actually good for us to see yeah we
should not be scared of them anymore
well there's like this is it though yeah
also i hate so do we though brian my
problem is i like your show pro russia
kind of drives me now i don't
no i like generals
a lot of generals who get on and who
have
uh there are a lot of you're just not
doubting russia i don't like i don't
anytime i see military experts who are
ex-military yeah like generals on
different news organizations that's cnn
a lot of times you'll find out that they
also have they also work for
defense contractors yeah they have their
hands and hands
they make some money off it i i don't
like it got it so they're just i saw how
you guys there's a agenda behind yeah i
saw how how iraq and afghanistan were
happening i saw
how do people make money off war yeah
yeah of course they're going to be like
you're skeptical because they you know
yeah yeah based off of no i don't know i
don't trust them no no that's fair i
don't know
yeah that's fantastic
you're terrified of russia brian count
loves i know it's very strange i keep
repping them so someone's going to
[ __ ] make a
no i just i just think i want there to
be a diplomatic solution here that no
yeah yeah yeah
i think they had a meeting uh because
it's like it's late it's night time over
there but they had one
when we were sleeping did you see that
that the
[ __ ] neo-nazis in ukraine a lot of
them were getting the military-grade
weapons zelinski was giving weapons to
all the all the citizens 18 well i think
there were a lot of those neo-nazis
they were fighting each other for
territory
are you serious no we don't want that
change
ukraine and russia spoke this morning
well russia doesn't want these sanctions
man the ruble fell 30 or something crazy
yeah we're really yeah these sanctions
there's more sanctions being done as
well free russia i mean ukraine
is crazy
it all comes down to nato that's are you
going to join nato or not yeah how old
is this jen is new two days ago
stage was set for these two that fell
off
yeah it didn't go well yeah they didn't
see it all comes down to what it might
be
don't be surprised if the east of
ukraine becomes russia
and they it splits up you never know but
the either way putin's like you're not
you're not joining nato
and that's the biggest thing wow
you don't want military bases he doesn't
want
american and european military weaponry
on his border
and there's got to be a way to work this
out yeah
you see they uh foiled a plan to
assassinate ukraine president they
caught the guys really yeah putin had a
hit out on that president they spoiled
the plan wow yeah goddamn
he's like number one on their list to
come after i would imagine
there it is
you'll be really embarrassed if you're
an assassination team and you don't pull
it off you know
yeah
uh we're all aware of the special
operation that was to take place
directly by the
catavoyance to eliminate our president
korean authorities have been tipped off
about the plot by members of russia's
federal security service who do not
support the war
you got the elite the group divided into
two with one being destroyed another's
under fire yeah so apparently they took
him out yeah
those those chechen guys but you you'd
be like
hey look at the guys with the huge necks
and those chin star beards i don't think
right there what's going on here yeah
that's so crazy man hopefully it stops
soon yeah
it's bad
they have this [ __ ] uh you can find
the video on youtube this neo-nazi guy
ukrainian guy going the west just wants
to see the thing is we like to kill we
want to kill and so they're giving us
our weapons and acting like they don't
know us but you know i'm like this guy
is a total sociopath
put him in jail right now yeah
this video is on youtube yeah you know
so so in what the kings used to always
do so if your country if you had your
kingdom back in the day and an army was
coming to take you over
the rulers of the of the so you're
saying you're surrounded and you know
that chaos is going to happen
the rulers of that kingdom or that
country and they actually touch on a
game of thrones since they would they
would be like all right we know that the
minute chaos happens the jails are going
to empty
and
they're going to cause havoc within our
own population and i can't have these
people so the king or the rulers would
be like gotta kill everybody in jail
call the prisoners all the pr all the
thieves all the murderers you cradle it
out to the people we know to give them
arms that's the problem yeah not all of
them
but a lot but you know they let out the
the like loose
yeah the ones that aren't like max not
murderers
they're not letting out the real bad
yeah yeah the ones who are on like petty
crime yeah and give them guns yeah yeah
like fraud and [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah
it's so crazy to me
all right jim what do you got
uh oh here we go
here we go
listen dude
i uh i'm a fighter yep and i like to
play where'd you learn to fight though
you know what dude i i have to take
classes i i go and i get a coach and i
learn something that costs me a lot of
money yeah dude go to fightcam it brings
the best workout in the world right to
your home
from your home it's fun learn to box
kickbox from your crib shut up right you
have world-class program elite trainers
premium equipment smart technology that
turns your work out into a great
experience thousands of classics quick
workouts we're talking about 20 minutes
we don't have 20 minutes man yeah listen
you don't have to be a professional
boxer if i can't got your back man
they've created programs that are
designed to teach you how to box and
kickbox all right full body workouts
it's great for your brain they get the
full package fight camp comes with all
the gear you need to start boxing from
your home including a standing punching
bag boxing gloves quick hand wraps smart
punch trackers i got somebody to teach
me how to fight yeah dude and your whole
family get involved man the whole fam
fight camp offers easy payments so you
can get your equipment and get started
right now pay over 24 months for the
less than the cost of a gym membership
plus fight camp offers free shipping
with a 30-day money-back guarantee just
go to fightcamp.com fighter to get free
shipping on your fight camp go to
fightcamp.com fighter that's
fightcamp.com
listen dude you're tired you need focus
you need energy and i got you you're not
lying dude i need to optimize did you
take your alpha brain no you didn't did
you take your new mood because i don't
like your mood okay did you take your
total gut health because your tummy
looks like it's a rumble absolutely not
on it's got you they've got you to they
will optimize you you got your shroom
tech which i swear by they got shroom
tech greens they have protein powder for
me dude you know what i mean i need some
coffee they got protein powder
yeah they got they got coffee they got
arabica dark roast for you need a
protein bar right now they got elk bars
do you [ __ ] with what if i don't want to
go to the gym do they have a workout
well guess what they got on at 30. they
got you can decompress to defy yeah
this home fitness program yes my warm up
your workout kettlebell athlete
morning mobility they are moving groove
they got everything you need a rope sign
me up go to honor.com fighter for 10 off
that's honest.com slash fighter 10
fighter
i like that shirt oh thanks the amazing
bambino uh amazing gambit you know this
is you know when uh donald glover was
trying to be spider-man and it went to
andrew garfield instead
really yeah
anyways
[Laughter]
i was like i was like just play cool
don't be cool be cool don't act like you
don't know what andrew garfield was
very cool actually andrew garfield was
in tiktik boom yes
amazing there you go brian you know uh
[Laughter]
out of it i saw it once i never got over
it but look at how i like how silly he
is right i don't know how much i believe
your mushroom story now
no that's true yeah
that means that you just want to true it
i also climb big whiskey mountain uh i
don't lie about that i'm not to lie
about those dumb things like i actually
did go to i always go to i think
i know all the channels it's just a hot
second channel i've never got a cancer
where i didn't actually go and watch
jazz you just can't name one oh yeah i
mean yeah
but i mean i'm not gonna lie about dumb
[ __ ] like that
what do i lie about i'll lie i'm down to
jazz bars but yeah
a lot of animal stories no no that
happened that happened what's that a lot
of animal stories yeah like that one
story where you told us the crocodile
was about to eat that kid or something
he fell off the tree it was lightning
and [ __ ] oh my god
my favorite was that's what you should
hey brian can you tell the story longer
yeah
no no i i don't lie about that because
that's something i heard but like for
example i'm not careful enough so when i
when i see uh uh when somebody throw you
know that thing with the guy the the
thing that landed the video yeah i was
like i saw that and then you're like but
you got to pay attention what's so funny
is you're so smart yeah you're so
[ __ ] smart but you didn't look any
further into that video that's the
problem is i get excited and i'll just
see it and i go that's true
i think the problem is how much you're
on social media it's so strange i don't
know if i'm on social media like tick
tock and like you just watched
when i go to youtube though i'll you get
that you hit that thing where you say oh
that looks like a great white shark
eating
a [ __ ] porpoise like that and then
you're like well let me see what's after
that well they're just
i think you just keep going and going
and going and going this guy's doing
parkour what the [ __ ] he's jumping so
and that's what happened he just will do
yeah i don't get in there i get it ryan
all right what do you got yeah all right
so apple has stated that they are
currently stopping all of the sales of
their products in russia oh no
yeah
i mean russia is like
we have our phones man
yeah i guess we won't get the new 13 max
you know like they already have their
phones there was a couple of businesses
that
yeah a couple businesses are are coming
out in support of ukraine by stopping
the sales of their products russian and
america
but brian that's what you said though
that's what [ __ ] up a country you [ __ ]
up there oh they're super [ __ ] yeah
our economy they're they're they're
they're sending them back i mean dude
you hit the oligarchs where it hurts so
they they have all their bank accounts
in switzerland and everything they have
all that's overseas that we seize their
yachts just freeze that [ __ ] yeah all
that's seized
it does not yeah i mean they might take
over ukraine but it's at a heavy price
yeah
it's gonna set the economy back and if
you're if you're a russian expat okay so
if you're a russian businessman okay
what people don't realize is that you
may have nothing to do with this crisis
they make your life hell if you have a
business in london and you're a russian
guy i promise you
it's not going to be i promise the
united states makes it impossible to do
business yeah that's what happens
i know that i know that for a fact yeah
yeah i know that for i found the entire
business
right going on what brian said the nhl
look there's been like a bunch of uh
because hockey has like a lot of russian
players and everything there's been a
lot of like brands like ccm like
regardless if they have any affiliation
with the russian invasion like if they
say anything about it they are banning
like they're taking all russian players
off of all brands they're trying to do
that just to put the pressure on putin
yeah okay dude like they took an effect
into everybody yeah they like they uh
ccm like ovechkin was you know like
russians are huge like bran like people
for ccm they're not using ovechkin or
any russian uh born player anymore for
any of their promotions they massimo
commercial like it's yeah it sucks for
them yeah well it's not only that so
when when my dad was friends with an
iraqi guy he's a businessman he [ __ ]
had nothing to do with this i hated that
yeah but he was a powerful guy with a
lot of money and i think he had interest
back in iraq yeah
and but he didn't like the [ __ ]
regime and
his bank accounts like that they would
the the they may see
[ __ ] with you like all of a sudden he'd
be like i can't get money out they're
stalling all my my my wife they would
just [ __ ] with you and he just ended up
being out of business that's what you
got to do if you're the american you
don't want to [ __ ] you don't want to
[ __ ] with the
united states we're going to make it
very tough yeah when it comes to get
twisted
we have some you know soy boys and that
stuff but yeah when it comes down to the
nit gritty yeah need a great night
if you were in the deep state rooms in
those private rooms which i am and i'm
not lying yes um
[Applause]
i can't believe i said that i'll just
chin uh edit that
out anyway say i was there but um
i i think what the idea might be is to
make life so hard on the russians and
the oligarchs and it's all because of
putin's invasion that there's some kind
of an internal coup d'etat like all of a
sudden they they kick him out they putin
gets removed and a more west friendly
regime regime i don't know good luck
yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying i'm like
that 27 years gangster yeah how long
have you been there yeah how long you've
been in 20 20 over 20 years yeah i
believe 27 years yeah he was also
essentially voted in as as president for
life did you ever see did you ever see
the
putin sort of the
inauguration when he had consolidated
power you ever see the where the car
pulls up and all the people are sitting
there as he's walking through the
kremlin and
like i mean you could see he was sort of
like voted in to be president
for life yes you know
he can handle that he's doing such a
good you ever see that you should watch
that he can't describe it to us though
oh it's [ __ ] but you see what a czar
it's a modern day czar yeah you see a
modern day czar where everybody is
clapping for him as he walks in his suit
alone all the way all the way all the
way all the way and then vladimir putin
and they announce him and they have to
go crazy oh yeah dude you know you know
you know what stalin used to do right
yeah stalin yeah you got to use those
never stopped clapping you told the
story yeah yeah you told me you told us
about it and they clap like this watch
everybody at the same time
i'm not stopping
i'm right because if you stop
you'll be the last guy to stop laughing
if he tells a joke oh i'm laughing he
would he'd be there and he'd watch to
see how long he would laugh dude if
we're doing this as soon as you stop go
hey
first one kill him kill him you will
point brian out if you guys are going
there well if it's me or him yeah yeah
hey hey hey hey hey he's the old man
yeah he's so clever
did you ever see how he would have his
his rank and file his inner circle would
know their results to die
to do yeah he'd do this he'd walk down
the way shake everybody's hand shake
everybody's hand shake everybody's hand
and then the one guy his main guy goes
to shake his hand and stalin just stands
like that looks at him
and just walks and then they take him
out the back and kill him see the guy go
like this see a guy go oh i'd sprint out
of them
dead
dead the next day
dude you know it's coming escape dude
yeah and you know why because you just
did something wrong you might have
missed a yeah you said something yeah so
you're dead
yeah that's fun and also if you were
standing guard if you were standing
guard by the door yeah they forgot about
you so you stand nobody gets in uh you
don't you can't pay
you 24 hours
i'm going to piss my pants you're crazy
stories i'd be a good soldier crazy
first of all who [ __ ] signs up for
this job you don't if you don't you
don't get it oh he's just like you know
it's very simple if you don't do it you
would you're going to kill your murder
your favorite made the list yeah you
made the list family he was shooting a
thousand innocent people a day at the
height of his power because
essentially what he realized he was a
true communist he just said so then i'm
going to use about him with
originally was trying to get stalin to
join him yeah and they started like no
no but hitler betrayed russia betrayed
him so then stalin was like i'm rolling
with [ __ ] it was really russia's war
yeah and then we came in before it was
the the winner brought the nazis to
their knees but but stalin um
he was he was a true
purist about of communism right and he
believed that human beings and society
could be perfected he could create a
utopia the 20th century was all about
creating perfection very similar
like in hitler's yes and so what happens
though he he said but here's the problem
and it's exactly what mao did it was
like if you like mal killed everybody
who wore glasses why because they read
and intellectually because they had bad
eyesight no so intellectuals had already
been
a bad eyesight though no it was because
they thought it was a flaw if you had
bad eyesight and the nazis did though
that's a different thing but but what
for that from mao and for stalin the
idea was this if you were an
intellectual you had already been
indoctrinated your brain had already
been contaminated with too many ideas to
re-educate you okay so the fact is
you're a lost cause you're an adult
you're already you're not a pure enough
comics i got to start with younger
people so he would kill entire families
of the intelligentsia he would kill them
all the whole family you were too
educated how would you know if you're
educated if you're like professors if
you were as a professor if you had a
degree yeah because he felt he felt
threatened by those those guys right
your own land so if with mao if you own
land if you are a landlord they accused
you of theft and they would bring you
before these sort of makeshift tribunals
and they'd humiliate you and then they
would shoot you so crazy yeah
so mao himself mao tong they never talk
about him malte tong
who killed uh i don't know maybe maybe
twenties later yeah maybe 20 30 million
people for starvation and everything
else i just want to say i'm super
blessed and super happy that i live in
the time yeah man
cause [ __ ] god damn yeah
real nice guy
yeah a real piece of [ __ ] so if you were
if you were just having to be smart and
just [ __ ] he'd be like oh no hell no
i don't mind they they were radicals
they wanted to restructure
society they wanted to create utopia's
perfect purity if you anybody who
believes in purity is uh it's going to
forget a long run
oh yeah oh yeah
1976.
i don't believe he's 5 11. that's a lie
but maybe not a change
not a chance
he was famous for saying as just a bunch
of dead a pile of dead people and stuff
like that yeah nuclear nuclear weaponry
he he let the um
west he was pretty pissed off about his
size small dick and then also his
hairline yeah
this was cult of personality [ __ ] his
hairline they got a huge statue statue
for him oh yeah i don't know it was
demolished no i've been to china they
had no they have statues of stones go to
the left they still have statues oh they
still have statues over yeah now it's
really yeah there's a giant one
demolished
who did my boy john cena like that look
scroll down i know it's so funny
[Laughter]
it looks great on soundcloud that's
hollywood
look at mal's hair though like hey dude
that's what i'm saying it's awesome like
you don't know in the world yeah that's
why he's so mean his hair his body first
of all if my hair was growing like that
i just shave it bald you would think
look at those look at that young
sociopath that was the worst they're
stalling those two they killed everybody
those two
that is the worst
oh my god
stalin was a [ __ ] monster his own
doctor said you should take it easy when
he was 80. he killed him killed him yes
he was just you just who was after
stalin but stalin was in a gang you know
he was in a gang if you read his early
life
they used to
you know
rob and kill and steal
why he searched richard nixon he's
standing right next to him with six feet
maybe so he p would be five eleven if
it's actually well these guys are old at
that point so they're a lot shorter but
yeah
all right what do you got jen
alrighty
there is footage of a deranged man
smearing feces on a woman in this i
don't know if that doesn't get stabbed
though you know yeah it could be they're
currently looking at
it came over dude i would take my dog to
new york city to central park and he
would she would roll in and bum [ __ ] oh
my god oh sorry in homeless [ __ ] sorry
in hobo [ __ ] she would just find it and
we'd we could hear her you just hear her
like i'm like chauncey what the [ __ ] me
and my girl
it was the worst and she'd be covered in
[ __ ] and [ __ ] yeah human there's
nothing i mean i think when they did the
smell test that human [ __ ] got like the
number one most ranked the worst ratchet
smells like literally you just scratch
your ass
and if it's a sweaty day it's like okay
i'm so like dookie for the next two days
man oh my chauncey once where you
[ __ ] dance
scratch your ass and make a mistake oh
and then you're driving and you're like
you can't shake it because you can't
leave that that smell doesn't go away
because you just don't human [ __ ] is it
has it's way worse than dog [ __ ] i'll
take dog [ __ ] over here i don't want
anything hey just use the poo pourri
before you take a [ __ ] man my [ __ ]
dog one time in new york right in uh
where the [ __ ] was it chelsea park or
whatever right he she what the [ __ ] i
came over i've been in new york so long
she grabs her rat i remember she i'm
throwing a ball she grabbed the [ __ ]
rat a big rabbit a big new yorker take
that [ __ ] right in half
oh my god
i'm like john jay
shag shack right now
goosh [ __ ] rat gun
i was like
i why i was like definitely [ __ ] got in
my mouth i was like
i went gargled with [ __ ] vodka jesus
christ
it's weird that people are into like
[ __ ] stuff like sexually like scat babes
it's insane i told you the first time i
knew rogan was a [ __ ] nut bag when
when he had he had i ever tell you the
story where he's like
he goes stay outstanding i'm like what
this when computers i didn't know what
the internet was this is how long ago he
goes you got to see this and he just
goes he hits
he goes okay come in now and he hits
like enter and he goes running outside
and i like a kid he's going
and i'm like what and i see this
beautiful ass in this japanese guy who's
dressed like a samurai and he's going ah
and i hear him like he i'm like what
what am i looking at and just sure
enough she just shakes a tar right in
his old mouth
he's like uh i was like and and rose
going
yeah i'm telling you that's the one
thing like [ __ ] that oh it didn't make
me gag i've never been the same
that was 20 years ago
from two girls one cup uh i don't watch
it i know i heard one i've never seen it
oh he's never seen it i can't oh man
that wasn't that's a terrible like in
college we used to leave people's
computers like their laptops on
lemonparty.org it's just three old gay
guys [ __ ]
just well that's just one guy getting
spitfired
just the wrinkliest guys in the world
all the best
that's the first time i really got to
know sasso we're doing a tv show and he
goes he goes my dressing room we all
have our dressing rooms and he goes hey
listen whatever you do my computer's
there and it's open and don't hit don't
hit enter because bathtub girl will come
up so don't hit enter because if you hit
enter bathtub is going to go it's going
to come up and i'm like what are you
talking about it goes my computer it's
just in front of your door just move it
and don't hit
don't hit enter
i'm like
i you're a piece of [ __ ] because of
course and i just go
and she's got
well it's a very heavy woman with
goggles and a tube from her ass in her
face and she's
sure there's a lot of stuff going on no
matter i've never been the same no my my
friend of course knew if they put up any
of that scat babe stuff where it's girls
and [ __ ] i'll throw up man i can't i
can't it's the one thing i can't watch
i can't do it i used to cover my buddy
um
we used to do like when
you get like a gay porn magazine and you
just take all the pictures out and you
just put them up on the dressing room
door just [ __ ] everywhere the little
thing the weird thing about that
is your buddy clearly gay men would go
to the store and buy the game taxis yeah
you know
actually or or they have a subscription
to it which
yeah and he he just had he's definitely
not gay but he had just there were [ __ ]
all over my like i was like this took
you a long time and i just screamed his
name
what else you got dinner
oh you guys want to see the video though
sure oh i don't know and they blur out
the girl
they don't blur out the guy but they
blur out the girl getting [ __ ] smeared
all over yeah
now where's where do you get the [ __ ]
from
we don't know apparently they tested it
and it was confirmed to be human [ __ ] on
her face too
they didn't blur his face out because
they're still active
they catch that punk [ __ ] oh my
god as of now
no oh he had it in a bag well he's not
well
he's not well you know he had to cover
somebody when [ __ ]
gosh this is why you got to carry pepper
spray
and six guns no she doesn't have time
for pepper spray she's just sitting
there i know there's nothing she could
do there she needed that brazilian lady
to look out after her yeah
to go shove that [ __ ] brazilian
girl to save her save me
lock me up how do you how do you even
fight a guy kidnapped me how do you
fight a guy with [ __ ] in his hand oh
you're not
[Applause]
these guys are cowards yeah he's going
after a [ __ ] woman yeah he's like a
troll on the internet they were remain
anonymous they know this girl can't
fight back
that's him if everyone knows
i was staying imagine if he gets caught
his friend's like well what are you
doing dude yeah i don't know if he has
friends but yeah and he probably history
he has a history of crazy
yeah i wonder why he picked that you
know schizophrenia hits men in their 20s
almost always
weird schizophrenia is very common in
men in their 20s i don't think i was 20s
i guess it might be early 30s
i don't know
what else yeti
this is just a silly clip i don't know
exactly what's going on but from the
context of the video it seems like this
woman is driving she has a vr set on her
so she can't see the road in front of
her but
i guess she had told the pers the
passenger to
steer the car while she's using this vr
set but her feet are still on the gas
and brakes
but why do this i don't know i don't
know what it is it says the metaverse is
live
oh oh my god [ __ ]
i said [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
wheel yeah junior [ __ ] [ __ ] what
does the will have to do with the break
[Laughter]
mom mom for [ __ ] listening to you
calm down mom hey hey mom you're the
dumbass yeah yeah why the [ __ ] you're
the one with breaking gas
what it's funny because she saw this
what you see
[Laughter]
dumb people doing dumb [ __ ] yeah
all right we have some combat sports
ones
a lot of people don't like this this is
going to happen this weekend we have the
fight companion the co-main event is
supposed to be rda versus rafael fazeev
that's injured
yeah so then the replacement is hanato
mokano and islam makachev actually
wanted to do it jump in tony ferguson
wanted to do it so this they would have
been awesome fights renato yeah that's
why everyone's bummed out
i'm not excited i know
and it's is it still five rounds
catch weight i'm not sure what the cash
weight is but yeah five round six what
does that catch weight mean they're not
actually out there fifty-five fifty-five
and seventy
no you know it wouldn't be fifty-two
because seventy-b
yeah what
because he has to make weight on short
notice yeah 60 pound yeah 160 so that
this does nothing for me i know it's a
bummer hard it does it's such a bummer
because if they had ferguson or
especially
that i've been so dope
and they had beef before why i don't i
wonder why the ufc didn't pull the
trigger maybe money market should cost
more money and that they're very
delegated a ton of money already on the
card so like we're good man maybe uh who
knows but everyone if i went to anime
junkies uh instagram everyone's like
over thousands of comments i'm out
bummed out yeah great yeah but i mean
fight was about to be lit i know dude
it's such a much such a bummer but
mcconnell is a badass cuz he's it's a
four day notice flying from straight
from brazil to fight rda raphael
poor mcconnell though man like yeah
i know it's not his fault he was like oh
this sucks he's like he's like i just
already do that i don't know
it's not my choice
what is rda's ranking right now he's
high six
he's still doing five or six still doing
it wow he just beat paul felder split
decision short notice though before that
he fell on some tough times yeah yeah
six right yeah mike chavette three chan
how was your chandler uh
who took great yeah he came out today
yeah he's great he's gonna fight tony
ferguson next yeah fun fight
what be
i don't like seeing tony ferguson
take
any more punishment especially the guy
who hits like chandler
yeah but they're both coming off losses
so
isn't there
is doesn't the commission look at that
stuff sometimes and say
look at what stuff
the he's talking about like
taking the beating i just think he took
i think he
was gonna stop guy from working though
you know what i'm saying like what are
you gonna do it's the way he makes peace
with your family
it really and he has no other you know
source of income yep
so at what price though right
it's fighting though sports
you watch the super bowl right different
how
pension money
you know
you have to know tony and comp said
pretty well yes cte but this is a little
bit different
i think what happened to him
with justin gaiji
and stuff like that i think that uh
charles oliveira yeah
yeah but who are you to tell a guy i
can't work i'm not you know what i'm
saying yeah
you don't have to watch don't watch it
just don't like it don't watch it yeah
it'd be easy for you don't watch it i
know that's how you're gonna fight this
hey look at me you're gonna watch it
guarantee it because you're a liar and
you're gonna watch it you've never been
that jazz thing either but the thing is
no i i'm not i don't but it kills no you
don't it doesn't though because you know
what you do you do a fight man with me
and chris for that because that's a
pay-per-view yeah i'll do that yeah but
then i won't watch it but my my thing is
yeah just put your bat when totally fine
you know what that's going to make such
a difference
you you just don't like seeing people
get beat up like i guess i should say
this it's a bummer i think you wish he
had more you wish he didn't have to
fight you wish he was set financially
that's exactly right there's nobody who
gave more to the sport there's nobody
was more dedicated there's nobody who
was [ __ ] so good
look at that winning streak nine fight
win streak yeah and then to watch
what happens to any human being when
they take that much damage there's a
there's a weird thing that happens it
seems with fighters i've seen it a
thousand times where
you have one fight and
it changes that yeah you just lose that
extra thing yeah i don't know what it is
i'm sure scientific age two yeah he got
you know father's gonna be good for so
long you usually have like a three year
run well we talked about it with tim
kennedy the toughest [ __ ] in the
world and he was doing a thousand other
things father time went you fought
castle
and and he knew and i think tim was like
oh i'm done i'm out yeah i'm out here
but thank god tim has so many options
sources a lot of options
yeah that's a bummer it's such let's see
i love tony though definitely watch that
fight that's that's the reason it's not
an easy fight either for either guy it's
a good fight
we'll just get you where's your money
uh chandler yeah yeah that's my guy too
right yeah
tyson fury says after his fight with
dillian white he's retiring so doesn't
mean no france isn't god no he said
there's one special fight that he would
do after not boxing boxing a special
fight oh
thank god yeah we don't want francis to
lose that fight i love him i'm with him
though it's like what else awesome what
else he's gonna do well but the anthony
joshua fights out there right like that
would be so big especially in [ __ ]
england that'd be the biggest fight of
all time he's amazing so i wish that
would happen but if he's done he's done
as long as he's down to fight frank
francis yes i'm with you on that too
this is amazing well i mean he's got a
heart i'm retiring 150
got loads of cars and properties all
over the world just going to sit back
with my hot button pina colada he might
get super fat and bored and maybe
depressed because i found a fight the
final countdown i'm done good for him
though
he should be acting he'll be amazing
everybody wants him in everything no you
don't have to do anything he's 150
million dollars in the bank yeah you
have to do anything but he'll he'll
he'll probably want to be in some kind
of a mix that's not boxing he's just
he's a great to where he gets to do
he's a great figure he's just fantastic
the best part is you don't have to do
anything right that's how this should
end like what a great story he's got a
great personality i think people want to
hear
he could be a great speaker yeah he's so
good like he's yeah he's great
here's two grand
my guy what about him i guess he was
getting text messages from peyton
manning for years but didn't know it was
him because it was just a number and the
and the guy well he knows it's peyton
now he would show the picture of cooper
and peyton together sent him that but he
just thought it was some random guy
studying he was like whatever weirdo
knows a lot about defenses
i got a message from a random number the
picture of him and uh back to the
manning pass the academy and i was like
that's so weird who would have this
picture i look back to the question they
all line up with certain events recently
we should see each other so i think i've
been ghosting peyton manning my entire
life that is [ __ ] funny
that's hilarious you can't ghost peyton
wow now the thing is the peyton just
stay on it and like keep her at like
he's dead for years so it's gotta be
multiple no no yeah if it's like two or
three
um this is a little older but i wanted
to show you guys this is in australia i
guess there's a higher end restaurant
that's banning people that have tattoos
or heavy jewelry
really because they look intimidating
they said what's heavy jewelry
this is an australian christmas tree
that's what i'm thinking but i mean i
don't see that as intimidating and
tattoos i don't think they are tim david
is their choice
yeah who [ __ ] wants to go there well
people don't want to eat because guys
with tattoos walk in are you is this
1940 yeah
well it's double bay's bedouin
between better one better win better one
better one is uh sydney australia
austria still laid back too heavy
jewelry and designer clothing
i don't know about them so if i wear
nice clothing that doesn't make any
sense at all uh can you see who the
owners are i think it might be they
might be
uh orthodox they might be muslim and
conservative or something like that
i don't know i i'm just guessing there
might be more it might be like
julian all right
it's a middle eastern restaurant it's
handsome
it also operates as a nightclub oh
they're they're they're pretending
they're not
they're not they're just regular
australians and it's an and it's a
nightclub
that's really interesting
do you think people get intimidated by
tattoos is it
a million dollar businessman is it a
weird um publicity thing do you think
no because i feel like it's interesting
because who's going to be i'm going to
[ __ ] go there handsome guy
i wonder why he does that
they said they marked on it was because
of intimidation they don't want other
patrons to be intimidated by other
people no one is right
i'm thinking of a [ __ ] you gotta expect
tattoos and you're intimidating you're
[ __ ] what are you doing
i don't get it i it might even be a fake
story no i saw him i hope this is fake
see here's on daily mail you know
there's traction
yeah i don't know about the daily mail
i saw it in multiple articles eatery
nightclubs owned by millionaire julian
tobias
counts tennis star nikki cairo is in
director among its clientele
weird man it's like it's like some some
restaurants you have to have a blazer
remember back in the day probably not
there a lot of restaurants back those
days they would have a blazer for you if
you didn't have one sometimes really
yeah
a lot of times gotta wear a blazer the
designer clothing thing doesn't make any
sense though that's the only weird one
oh well they were like in april fool's
joke but they're not
oh yeah i don't buy it yeah
you don't want the [ __ ] patrons to be
scared that don't make any [ __ ] sense
kelly kay has all the jaw
yeah he's got it very so who is that guy
the director
of what uh thor ragnarok and jojo rabbit
oh okay oh jojo that's a good one
the thor is the guy right i'm out but
judging rabbit i'm right back in oh
thought ragnarok is so good i know i
don't but the
guy came from space has a cape on him
out
and he's dating rita ora
i believe so there was a headline about
him
recently where they were on a film and
there it was like them making out and
then there was another girl making out
with them too oh i remember that you
remember yeah guy parties yeah he gets
down it's thor movies
this guy's 102. this is a quick one so
he's winning gold medals in his bracket
which is 100 to 105 year old
i can't believe they even have sprinting
for 100 100 i know right yeah
i i have skepticism and how fast are
these two hey man i don't like how you
and china show no this one's a reality
they got duped
that's why i have skeptical hippo eyes
now about everything how's this time for
you hey at 100 it took him almost i
could run that backwards
at 102. dude is there a five of him
running dude i could smoke this guy yes
you would i'm trying to get the gold you
get him with your back there he goes but
you ain't in a hundred or 205 dude i'll
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] look at these
[ __ ] i'll pull a joanna man and
[ __ ] get all through
it's impressive he's able to run yeah
102 yeah
not bad looking too for a hundred
percent
that's good
with the heart like that that's
important yeah still
oh yeah that's just dogs those are dogs
you won the gold huh he's the
he wins all of them
and um
one of the big fans of the show who does
memes a lot added mentality yeah
world what was that i forgot so he sent
this in for you guys it's just a rachel
ostovich appreciation thank you sir
thank you
appreciate it there's this one
yeah she fights in bear now there you go
here but ooh jesus but she um her man is
the pro ball uh safety for the chargers
there you go yeah he's a stud
oh thank you sir for sending that wait
go back go back to those pictures
the girls yeah
those are those are some
yeah there's a whole situation going on
there wow
now she's not fighting anymore she's
she's in bare knuckles yeah she's in
bkfc that's a thick guy and she just
beat paige i think yeah she beat paige
yeah she's she's gorgeous russia or
something
absolutely not hawaii right she's
hawaiian
yeah
rachel ostovich yeah sounds like a
russian name i wonder if she's from
kazakhstan originally or something
i'm going to make that call look it up
look it up watch this
uh wikipedia
yeah cause she's born in uh hawaii yeah
yeah she lives there
originally her parents are from austin
is definitely not a hawaiian name i'm
with brian on that their parents might
be from kazakhstan um first life all
right no you go to go go up to like
early life i saw that it's just usually
tells like their family [ __ ]
she was born in hawaii
keep going down chin
yeah she's the prettiest fighter on the
planet
just person it might be somewhere in the
personal life
you can see um
no you can probably see
it doesn't say you can hear it if you go
nationality you might or type in parents
nope
rachel ostovich's parents
your listener or nationality as
americans you have to look up ethnicity
yeah
i'll dm and ask her
thanks chappelle
not there i think we just look at the
last name also if you find it
no
all right yeah brian's the one that
really wants if you type in rachel
ostervich ethnicity something's going to
pop up hawaii i bet
hawaii in the united states
and then let's see who says people ask
is rachel
hispanic see what it says
she says born in hawaii then her dad
looks super hawaiian that's her
boyfriend that was the bad person oh who
beat her yeah yeah
is rachel
you know click on that
no
it just keeps saying it might be a
mystery
maybe she doesn't maybe she was adopting
but that she's lying
she could be a doctor
i don't know no i'll answer that no
yeah but you know that right you know
that buddy hey i don't know dude yeah i
just
stupid conspiracy
[Laughter]
hold on
uh you can't tell britain
and ireland oh really it doesn't say
could you stand like brian thomas
weird
[ __ ]
canada 1911 1920 sounds very russian
though doesn't it
no i'll give you that it does not sound
very she looked like a wave kazakhstan
they look that way so
yeah they look sort of asian yeah yeah
yeah she definitely looks like she has
some asian she either way yeah i was
thought she was rushing she's very
pretty my bad and i think that's it her
man is a super baller is he yes that's
it that's it this is a small one
for the chargers yeah stud super stud
that's it that's it that's it is he's
charging more for batman yeah they're
going to try because i guess they do it
in europe for different movies to charge
a little bit more i saw it it's going to
be charged like 18.99 for a batman it's
a dollar more than whatever regular
dollar more yeah
that's cool but still 1899 is crazy for
a movie theater are you cool with 17. no
i don't like i don't like it anywhere
near wait that's how
how much movies are nowadays apparently
just a regular ass movie yeah
you want to go see movies that man's a
dollar more seems like a good deal
really
you went to movies a lot right i stopped
going to movies
as a kid i went all the time and then my
the only time i ever go to the movies
now is taking my kids yeah kid movie so
you go quite often now right uh no maybe
once every two months i don't know
i didn't go for years and i started
going again and i didn't realize how
much of that freaking price jump it is
can you find out what the temperature in
appleton wisconsin is right now sure
negative seven let's just see
there's a lot of uh dagestanians and uh
you know who's from appleton wisconsin
houdini
uh
is that right yeah you're right the
magician you're right about that yep 30
years ago
oh overnight's 15 that's funny
hey you're gonna you're gonna love that
clothes
that club is a lot of fun at least
there's no snow yeah i had a great time
at that club
no look no snow yeah
for me brian's gonna freeze his ass off
for now we can apples
uh next wednesday is shauban friends at
hollywood improv and also next week is
nashville tennessee zaney's march 10th
through the 12th
and then chicago is march 24th to 26th
get your tickets at thickboy.com
uh i'm in appleton wisconsin with jase
nellis thursday friday saturday this
thursday phoenix arizona stand up live
next weekend march 11th to the 13th by
the way that's a friday to sunday i
can't believe it louisville kentucky
louisville i'm coming to your horse farm
uh i got jason ellis march 17-18 miami
florida of course and always march 25-27
it is spring break in miami
oh we were there last year first there's
myself a little airbnb
we're ready
yeah okay uh march 10th through 12th
i'll be in uh popping ass springfield
missouri yes at the blue room comedy
club and then april 8th and april 9th
salt lake city utah wise guys comedy
club and you guys been to springfield
before missouri never uh i've not and i
was supposed to do that is that where
the simpsons is based out of that's just
springfield
springfield illinois too though there's
a springfield a lot of places but i
think it's springfield missouri how
where does it on your hey mr conspiracy
how weird is it with the simpsons they
predicted trump they predicted uh
ukraine russia like they're they're
predicting they did
the simpsons the cartoons oh they did
they predicted all this wow
well listen man i'll be bringing brian
is in oregon
check it out on rockfin we had a great
podcast yesterday yeah what was it about
it's just we it's wwe because sam will
come at me with some concerns i know but
what did he come at you with uh
he came at me with the fact that
that ukraine it was a kingdom called
kazaria and that this was written a long
time ago and i'm like all right sam well
here we go it was written this war
yeah and have you ever this is a weird
conspiracy and maybe it's conspiracy but
a lot of the russian troops that the
ukrainians caught they're like we were
told this is a drill this isn't war this
isn't a takeover we're told this was a
dream oh i've heard something like that
too yeah yeah yeah like whoa what the
[ __ ] well he's a real bullet yeah yeah
yeah
a lot of the russians you know the
problem with a lot of those russian guys
is that they
when you're on the eastern side they
have girlfriends they're all they all go
back and forth
and they also feel like they're rushing
so what happens is they're there and
they're like well my girlfriend's
right she lives in that [ __ ] building
you know there's a [ __ ] problem 100
it's a problem yeah but there's been a
lot of them like whoa this is the actual
takeover war it's not and they're like
we thought this we're told this is a
drill i don't know
i i don't know i i don't either there's
been a lot of but like i've i've heard
it but not like not like no yeah i don't
know i i just think that
yeah i this sucks for everybody and i
think the average russian is like dude
no they're like no no business i got you
know i would go into ukraine on the
weekends they would go party
yeah it's just not all right i'll see
you next week nashville i'll see you
around this week springfield missouri